hello word so today I want to talk why
syphilis is a really cool tool I don't
know
software engineering technique or
whatever it is for empowering developers
so the first question to ask is why
you're interested in learning these so
maybe to start that we should go one
step backwards and answer the question
what is several s I sure you already
heard it million times but it will be
brief so several s is computing
execution as an utility so it's like the
water top at your house you just drink
it you flush your toilet you wash your
clothes use it to solve different
problems that you have at your house but
you really don't care how you're
building have structure the pipes and
how the city manage to deliver the water
from the central water tower to your
house and you don't care how the country
gets that water and how it comes to you
you don't care about the infrastructure
or the water you care that it's just
there and you can drink it whenever you
need it and one thing about water or
other utility is that you just pay as
much as you so if one day hot and you
want to water all your garden you will
pay quite a lot of water because you
feel your pool you water your garden
it's very hot summer day so yeah but
then maybe you want the holidays and you
didn't spend anything no water used
because there was no one at home and
then your bill of water is close to zero
same happens with electricity and other
utilities and idea behind several s is
similar is to have computing execution
as in utilities so you can use it as
much as you want it can be scale so if
you need to fill pools of computing
power you are able to and you don't care
how your provider of computing power
solves that problem for you
but if Sun months you are on holidays
and you don't want to have any computing
power you just don't pay for it
so to summarize thoroughness is
computing power as an utility it can
scale automatically and you pay as much
as use so why you care about
learning this why you care that's a
valid question and you should ask it all
the time before starting to learn
something there's so many technologies
around them and it's hard to decide
sweetheart
which one she should choose and so first
I will leave my answer to several
developers if you're a server developer
several less is the next thing after
containers I sure you learn docker a
couple of years ago now it's time to
learn several s it says how the
evolution goes if you want to keep on
the trend and you want to have a cool
job for the future you should learn this
so sorry man but if you're a client
developer then the story becomes a
little bit different because your main
job is not to produce server so why you
should care if you're a web developer or
an Android developer iOS developer game
developer all these client facing
developers that are not working in the
server why they care about learning
serverless and I think my first answer
is if you're a client developer and you
learn several s you will become way free
yes free how I how you become free huh
developer because I think it's a very
easy first step to become a full stack
developer and I'm not meaning with this
that several developers will be like
discarded and we don't need them anymore
no no no I'm meaning that now as a game
developer or web developer you're able
to solve some problems that are pretty
simple without the need of asking and
our developer for help so if you're at
home doing side project or you have a
small company or you have a project with
little people then you can be more
independent and solve more problems so
you can create a small server that
connects to a database and return
something or that process some data or
resizes are immature
you are able to get done a lot of things
with very little knowledge because if
you're a web developer you might already
know JavaScript very well so it's just
about learning some tools to work in the
surrealist world if
game developer major uses C sharp so you
can also go to the net and start working
with several s so there is quite easy
steps in order to get started and I
think several s is a really good way to
get started with the cloud because I
don't think the whole Lifan AWS the
whole several s landscape has been done
with the mentality that people don't
need to be experts to get started so
getting started with these tools it's
way easier to get started with instances
and B PCs and all that kind of older
stuff if you want to get started with
cloud if you want to be more independent
if you want to become a full stack
developer you should learn several s so
now that I convinced you I will show you
some steps to get started so let's go to
the screen and let's go to it so the
first thing you need to do in order to
get started with several us if you don't
have one is to create your AWS account I
have made a video about this I will link
the link of this video in a card in the
corner or then in the description box
below so you can go there and check how
to create a secure free AWS account so
follow the instructions and you will be
ready after doing that you need to go to
the server les dot-com web page and
install and configure several s
framework and forgot there are
instructions there pretty
straightforward so just follow those
four steps from which you have already
done one that is number three that you
created their account download now
download several s and then configure
the provider credentials after you have
your AWS account and then you're ready
to go after you have that done those two
things now you're ready to go to your
terminal create a new directory I will
call it first thoroughness project you
can call it whatever you want I will get
inside the directory and then I will
create my first several s project that
is pretty straightforward
it's a let's create that says template
in early as note yes
that's just name and the name of the
project so this is the easiest way to
create an
new Taurus project you just do sls that
is several s that is what you just have
installed a soulless framework create to
create the project you pass the template
name in this case we are going to use
AWS hours our cloud and nodejs as our
framework and then the name of the
project that we will need pretty
straightforward just press enter and
service framework will generate some
files for you then I always do NPM you
need that yes because that creates a
empty package JSON so if I need the
pendency or something I will put them
there after that I open this in atom and
you can see that we have three files
first one is 200 is package.json and
salustiano let's visit the cyril sgml
first the several HTML is the file where
all the 7s framework configuration is
these are fine specific for this
cellulose framework here you will define
the service name that is the name that
we just put when we created a project
the provider under runtime that's come
from the template in this case is AWS
and the nodejs 6.10 and then you will
also define all the resources AWS
resources including the lambdas and the
api gateway so if you scroll down the
template already has one lambda function
call hello that is Manoj with a handler
code that is in the file handler and in
the method hello we are going to go
there in a second but if we want to
define an API gateway that is from front
door to our lambda that is the end point
we just do this event then we put HTTP
because this will be triggered by an
HTTP event that is the path hello and in
the method get' so easy like that we
create a new endpoint that will trigger
this piece of code it's very very simple
then we can go check this package JSON
that doesn't have anything interesting
for now and there you have the handler
yes that has the information has the
code on how to run this
and here is a very simple hello method
that comes out from the template and the
only thing you will see is an object
response and a callback that is
returning that response we are going to
modify that response object to just
change the message and lo and congrats
on your first solo spreadsheet so you
can see that we are deploying the right
project and then this body will include
also an event that is the event that
comes from the handler so usually in the
handlers you have three parameters that
when the context on the callback the
event is the information the lambda is
getting from the trigger in this case
from the API gateway and you will be
able to see it in the body and the
response is a 200 status code so then
when we save this and we go back to our
terminal
we can run SLS deploy that means
serverless deploy so this is deploying
this project into AWS because we have
configured the credentials from
serverless framework your your AWS
credit just into service framework is
possible to just with a small command
put all this project into your cloud
similar framework will package these and
then deployed several astragalus using
cloud formation but you don't need to
know what is going on in the background
to understand what is going on at the
beginning so I will speed this up
because usually this takes a couple of
minutes and you cannot do anything after
the deployment is complete you will see
this service information that will show
you the service name the stage we have
not defined a stage but several s
remember by default if you don't define
the stage will put it to stage step you
can have any name if you defined it then
with the region if you don't define any
region it was just deployed US east one
that is North Virginia you can put in
the AWS region that you like the stock
name does the close formation name of
the stock that you don't need to know
for now we don't have any API keys we
have one endpoint that is
one and one function that is also there
and then if we graph the end point that
well and we paste it in our browser we
can call the lambda you see that the end
point is a get in the path hello so if
we put it in the browser we will see
that there is the message hello Congrats
on your first service pressure and then
the input that is all the event that
this lambda is getting from the API
gateway this was a video for today I
hope you liked it if you did give a big
thumbs up and if you have any questions
comments concerns things you want to see
in the future just let them know in the
comment box below I always happy to make
content that you want to watch